we are actually here for a private YC
event the global growth conference which
has growth stage founders coming from US
and China and I know Cindy you're
talking at the event so thank you so
much for taking the time to meet with us
before the event you know why don't we
start off with you know can you tell us
a little more about yourself and what
really motivated you to start bi Pickett
absolutely so I started teaching young
kids English when I was fifteen years
old so that's about almost 20 years ago
and what really most what motivate me to
you all start VIP kid is the possibility
of inspiring and empowering every child
for the future and just think about how
we can connect the world of the best
teachers best content and the most
innovative learning experiences online
it's just amazing so I you know through
all these all these years teaching young
kids English I figured the pain point
for parents today is for their kids to
be able to learn from the best teachers
and then the curriculum they learn
nowadays are mostly out-of-date and they
really want something fun and then you
know content based so on when we started
VIP kid it just changed everything for
the parents and the kids now that many
children China are able to learn with
the best instructors from North America
learning content based knowledge based
on Common Core State Standards and
children having so much fun and this
great thing for the teachers as well
yeah this just fulfills my dream of
making learning so different for the
kids today and the were still working on
it to build something even more amazing
for the future that's fantastic I
remember when I was at a deal in Beijing
you know I had heard about we advocates
but I didn't realize that you know you
pretty much built a global marketplace
from day one you know I didn't realize
that a lot of your English teachers were
from the US all right and you were
teaching kids in China can you talk a
little more about that because I thought
that was interesting and especially you
know before you talk about that also
give some idea for the audience on what
is the platform what is the product do
you provide the curriculum and how does
it work as the
so in the world of learning we have this
after school tutoring space where
children go learn after their schools
right so this is extremely important in
Asian countries particularly in China we
our parent their parents in China spend
15% of our household income in
after-school tutoring services that does
not surprise me at all given I come from
India it is very important enough for
the children because then they can get a
tutor on things they really like or
things they need to work on right so for
the space we would usually have a brick
and mortar are tuning institutes
operating across the country so those
are usually 20 40 people classrooms with
children learning there after school for
like three hours a week or two times of
two hours and we kind of thing but then
um what VIP kid provides nowadays are
very very different from the brick
mortar setting so we provide this live
one-on-one 25-minute classes with uh
online tutors teaching live from the
comfort of their homes mmm so for
children they're there they're not
learning in a classroom set up with a
twenty other kids there by themselves so
this is very you know private lesson 101
and then the teachers are the best we
can find a across a globe because if you
think about it we're today working with
over twenty thousand teachers in the US
and they're the best we can find and
everyone has to go through a very highly
selective interview process we only
admit five percent of the teacher
applicants so children really enjoy it
for the first time in the inner life if
they can feel free to choose to work
with teachers that they feel the best
help them learn and we're able to match
the best teachers to them in the system
so this is about the teachers a second
the highlight of their product is that
the content the curriculum content is
developed by a VIP kid curriculum team
we've got over 200 professionals working
on this we iterate at a weekly basis so
children really like it because it's
based on common
it's not just language learning it's not
just about grandma we collaborate it has
like math language and arts science
social studies all the content in it so
it's really fun and then when they learn
these are content it's not just about
the language is the content it's a
culture it's a critical thinking
leadership a lot of things behind it so
to know having a great great time and
all these curriculum are designed for
students out of the u.s. so don't speak
English and then they're designed for
online learning specifically so the way
the things are sky fold is so different
from what it would have learning in the
classroom setup so a very unique content
for the students we have long term short
term assessment view it all the way
through so students also do a lot of
project-based learning after their
session time and then they just present
to teachers the next the next the next
session so it's a Content and lastly
learning experience is so different they
have access to learning portal at all
times
so they would usually take a 25-minute
session two to three times a week but
then the rest of time they would spend
their time on their learning portal
reading books doing you know practice
sessions working on a whole lot other
things we provide for them so learning
is consistent and we have all the data
so we're able to do better learning
analytics for the parents and also
provide a children with more
personalized or learning content got it
great that's fascinating because I think
you touched on like at least three
elements that make it different and I
wanted to probe on one or two of them
because there are a lot of EdTech online
platforms but I think the scale that you
have a t achieved it truly makes it
unique so you said you have 20,000
teachers all from the US is that right
mostly and some from Canada okay so from
Kelvin North America North America got
it and how many students do you have no
we up to date we've got over 200,000
students along with VIP kid okay and so
and they are they all from China they're
mostly from China and we have over two
percent of our students are coming from
countries like Japan Indonesia our
German
Australia and some of them you know in
the US as well got it great so
one of the questions I had for you is
you know how long is this course or
program like when does the child join
VIP kids and how do you keep them
motivated because it was interesting you
mentioned that the session length is 25
minutes and the rest they're doing you
know they have to do on the learning
platform so what motivates them to stay
on the Blatt file that's a great
question so our student the youngest our
three and a half okay and the oldest
goes up to 13 years old okay what
motivates the kids is the the learning
interest that brought to them by lively
encouraging North American teachers as
well as the engaging content that is
very personalized to their need and also
the Akemi fide learning experiences on
our learning portal
so today children's make their own
decisions of what they want to learn
what they want do not want to learn
parents cannot really you know good luck
trying but really has to become that
neutral sake motivation that I
personally believe is very very
important so if the child if feels like
he is empowered encouraged by puter
encouraging him all the time say great
job brilliant wonderful you're really
great the best didn't ever Totten he
felt so great about learning that the
love of learning sticks there so it's
really important that we do that with
our kids so they're able to set out to
learn and explore themselves in the
future and second thing I think really
important for the kiddos we will help
them feel competency for the future so
by that I mean very interesting class
design instruction designer or content
that Skyhawk very interesting so for one
class we had a question for the kid and
asking them if you have all these rights
on the floor how would you solve the
problem problem solving right so you
would have then have a chicken you have
the vacuum clean they and a lot of other
brooms everything so true you always
want to go for the chicken because the
thing is fun you can eat right so it's
like a lot of a competency to help them
through weather logic think like
thinking and everything else so
children's view they're not just
learning their there they're having fun
and also they're building different
skills that they can have a future apply
to other subject areas of their
learnings great intrinsic motive that's
that sounds fascinating and I think the
as you mentioned the one-on-one
interaction with the teacher and that
motivation also you know keeps them
going to try different projects on the
platform
I thought you mentioned one very
interesting thing which was he said you
know you're looking at North America for
the teachers so my question there was
you know you started this company in
China for custom and your students from
China are the ones learning how did you
go about building this great network of
teachers and especially for someone
coming from China to the US and related
to that like today you mentioned you're
at a five percent acceptance rate so
what is it that you really look for when
you're selecting a teacher to the
platform yeah so you know we are looking
into a few quality that is really
important to us for teachers that work
with the I think it one one of the most
important being love of kids so you
really have to wanting to help children
learn and grow you you know it's it's
not an easy job right you worked with a
children who you know very mostly barely
did not speak English and they're you
don't speak Mandarin or Japanese or
Russian and then you're there to help
them learn they're in half year old this
is this fun but at the same time very
very challenging so that intrinsic
motivation of the teachers is really
really important and secondly
qualifications and experiences we're
looking for people with a bachelor's
degree people have a teaching
certificate it can be a TSO TEFL ESL
base certificate it can be a k-12
teaching certificate so you really have
to have that experience of working with
kids or student and so that you know the
best way to to teach I mean being able
to speak a language and be able to teach
is a very very different skills right in
China we have you know
1.7 billion people everybody speaks
Mandarin but very few can teach so if
you think about it's really important
that somebody who's been the profession
long enough that knows how to engage our
students learning interest and and
lastly we're looking for teachers who
are able to learn really fast learn yeah
teaching online kind of different it's
not in the classroom you have this
little video camera you don't never gate
and then so it's really important that
you learn fast but uh we're also
although we only have a five percent
acceptance rate today we're also
thinking about how we can better empower
our teachers because we think many of
the teachers are really great it's just
if they cannot figure out how to teach
online really fast they wouldn't pass
our interview today but if we do more
efforts and help them more I think but
they have all the fundamentals that we
need in being a teacher in North America
it's not an easy job you know it's not
exactly the highest paid position and
you spend many many more hours
out of the classroom you know it's a
ratio is significantly surprising I
think right it just devote all our time
and love to the kids and I think they
all deserve the best opportunity
teaching online and teach students
across the globe so we would love to
spend more time building like better
empowerment also it can help them more
that's very interesting because when you
know before I was going to talk to you
today I just looked online in the in
YouTube and the first video that came up
was from a teacher who said I failed my
first VIP kid interview but here are the
tips to you know pass the interviewer
how should we become a better teacher
and I thought that was very interesting
rated content it's very very she's
searching for any company in the world
you wouldn't find all these like
professionally made content from the
supply side of the user of ourselves
right so yeah so let's go back to when
you launched the company right because
you had to have a global marketplace
from day one you needed these teachers
from North America and students from
China so talk a little bit about the
first year when you launched how did you
source these teachers yeah that's great
is it the first part of your question um
so the first year and a half was
very very challenging and nobody bought
the idea from both side of the
marketplace parents thinks it's just
challenging for kids to learn and they
wouldn't imagine and then investors are
thought this is such a dumb idea that
you can never find enough students and
teachers but for from the teachers side
also it took a lot of efforts to
convince people so by the end of the
first year and a half we ended up with
only 20 teachers Wow and 200 students so
Bravo to all these people here to our
mission but I think it's just if people
don't see how it looks like it's very
hard for people to understand how it
might work right so we did spend the
most time you know first and a half
talking to everyone just sit down with
them explain be very patient and you
know have them understand how it will
look like and then if necessary
demonstrate so I remember I think for
the first 20 teachers I think I talked
to most of them and for the first 10 I
definitely see recruiting myself so need
to on skype by then we didn't really
have a system yet demonstrate to
teachers how it could work like you
could just high tier students writing
this it's not hard yeah but if you think
about it for many people who do not
speak Mandarin and who thinks this is
really the hardest language to learn
mostly it's scary to teach young kids
who don't speak English so we just have
to tell teachers it's really easy so if
you say hello my name is Cindy what is
your name they'll get it is that 50% of
communication is non-verbal right so
allah just be patient and explain to
everyone talk to the people find out
people who's wanting to get on board at
over early stages a very risky
experience but by the end of the year
and a half we were able to figure out a
few of things one is how do we find
teachers and students right so the thing
that we found is referrals see if you
have a great quality product people
would love to talk to their friends
about it and if it's bringing them extra
value for the student side
less expensive tuition for teacher side
more income second thing is we figured
out
how do we build a content online yeah it
must be stifled very differently from it
is in 40 more classrooms and also with
teachers who do not speak children's or
first language and lastly what are the
system of functions that parents and
students and teachers meet the most so
you start building something there we
have a three-party system there it's not
just like share rides riders and drivers
we have one more so parents yeah and the
parent is the customer that's paying for
it yes and children makes decisions so
it's really important to keep them both
happy got it and so how did so on the
teacher side you start you said after a
year and a half you had 20 and how did
you do that on the student side you had
200 oh yes it's the same thing so we are
first four students come from one of our
most early investors San ovations
adventures and four out of the four
students three comes from the company so
we have there's the two children of
their CFO and the went out of the
general console and then what more comes
from Jessie my co-founders of a friend
so friends and families and then we
started with receives four kids and you
know they love it yeah but for the first
few classes we have to sit the child
down in one of the conference rooms so
in a generation ventures our offices we
used to be incubated there so it's like
similar to this I see why's the office
and then teachers in the other classroom
but like a conference room and then
parents feels like they have to watch
both sides and how they how they go it's
really fun to to see how they work
together and we didn't know like we need
to have a very solid a backdrop of the
walk and there was a really colorful
painting that blurs the camera so even a
lot of experiences build up from those
and but then after the forced for
students we then had a lot of videos
that we can show to other parents like
Oh see this is what your child looks
like when they live online and the
particular one thing was very impressive
when we saw one over
very first student Lily I think she
lived enough France when she was really
little and she was seven but then she
hit it English and but then one day the
video camera turned off teacher went
away
Lily's hitting the classroom for like
extra ten minutes and just went back to
see what's taught in the classroom and
then she keeps saying teacher come back
where are your so great that's a great
sign but yeah so she loved it so you see
how the connections are Buick Ross the
screen and it's something that even
beyond my imagination and today of
course I hear stories all the time from
our teachers saying oh these are my kids
you know the country you love them so
much but then it's it's really very
different when you see all these
connections are so well connected the
world between the teachers and yes and
when exactly did you launch was it 2013
yes we launched you know we've
officially launched to market March 2015
so it's two years and a half ago but we
started October 2013
so exactly four years ago okay so one of
the things I've noticed even in the US
market places right market places that
are a long slog because it takes both
sides to build liquidity I mean Airbnb
has talked about this quite a lot as
well it took them quite some time to
build that so a year and a half you had
20 teachers 200 students at what point
did you really think this is gonna work
was it at that point or it was at that
point and also a little a few other
little points along the way I think
we're we're really looking for is
efficacy through that year and a half
because uh for students learning outcome
that means the world right you just have
to be valuable to the kids otherwise why
would you want to be building this
company because it could be criminally
you know successful but doesn't really
allow us right so I think this is
something we look for and after a year
and a half we find our students love the
program high retention enjoy it they are
taking Isha tubes asking their parents
say can I have a class every day their
moms like make a little bit expensive
can we just do it a little bit
and it's never happened before it's
always a mom saying can you learn more
in case they know and also on the other
end of the equation our teachers we need
to make sure that this works for them
this is something that they relish and
they feel comfortable doing they want to
do this for long term and you know in
this you know one of the oldest Chinese
saying we have like you have all the
students across the globe but they use
them like fruits to metaphor it and then
it's like same thing right we're now
bringing students across the globe to
the teachers I mean teachers in North
America are really great motivated
people I think they all love the kids
like themselves right so they just they
feel this is and also that the extra
income makes a lot of sense and it just
helps the families so much yeah I'm in a
way that I couldn't have imagined that
visited a few very small cities you know
like Utah were any like cut off other
states and then there there aren't a lot
of local job opportunities I mean even
if teachers wanted to make extra income
where can it go except for like driving
uber or some other retail opportunities
and now today all many of the retail
jobs are gone so it's really hard for
them so I'm really happy that this
provides all these great value for the
teachers and then so by that point we
figured this is working and everybody
loves it I didn't kiss I love it teacher
loving parents love it you know why
don't we then scale I think then you
have all these matrix that the venture
capital people would evaluate on
translate it would be like a retention
and LTV right and then if everybody is
referring everybody it's a low
acquisition cost right and so
everybody's very happy with where we are
and then we're able to really grow this
sell program but I think all comes down
to efficacy for both sides got it and
how big was your team in the first one
and a half years Oh like 20-ish people
so we started with a few people so we
believe in the lean startup startup way
so
have to build from very small team and
then just gradually crew your team so we
had a very few people for the first uh
you in half but uh I think they all
based in China they yeah they are okay
by then and today you know you obviously
have scaled it very well from twenty to
twenty thousand teachers and two hundred
more than two hundred thousand students
so how is your team today how big is it
where are they located so our team today
has over three thousand people so most
of the team are locates in a Beijing
okay you have office in Shanghai but we
are very proactively building an office
here in the Bay Area and we believe that
our teachers are all here it only makes
the most sense if we want to empower
them the best have a dual headquarter
here you San Francisco close to you know
all the teachers so we're reviewing up
tea a team here in San Mateo oh that's
interesting so how I mean it makes
natural sense now that you have twenty
thousand teachers but how did you I'm
curious how did you manage recruiting
teachers being in Beijing the last four
you know two and a half to three years I
think um community would be the key word
I think and of course referral virality
would be the second key word right after
community empowerment something we
believe in so teachers like if they're
in the US and very disenfranchised
dislocated already so across the Pacific
Ocean is not that far away yeah but uh I
think teacher for the past 20 years so
teachers feel that uh my me and my team
on really understands what they need the
most and really are there for them all
the time so from day one they feel that
they're so connected to the community
that they want to contribute so on the
way we do this is by referrals and our
teachers would as you see on youtube
post their own experiences five-minute
video we're very well educated and then
people ask questions and then they would
answer them and they would say hey if
you wanna apply click on this link
mm-hmm and if they refer a teacher's
successfully we'll definitely give them
like a motivations on
referrals and then teach a few
incentivize to do this but I think at
the very core though is teachers feel
that they're hurt and they're empowered
in everything that we do on a daily
basis so we communicate to our teachers
very frequently we have a weekly
newsletter that goes out to every
teacher sharing with everyone what's
happening across board so you know a
letter from San Francisco or Beijing
doesn't really make it because if people
feel culturally they're so connected and
we do work with the professionals in
Beijing that our North American people
so like from a US or Canada so our teams
are like although located in Beijing
from here so and also teachers are very
special teacher education educator
community so you know with the team in
this share economy world or marketplace
world but from an education perspective
makes them feel that were the most
trustworthy efficacious learning company
that they've ever seen
and we really implement every little
thing we we you know we do making sure
that we're doing mhm the whole efficacy
goal as we go move that word although
we're scaling really fast and teachers
know it and they can see all the
iterations now Creek Coulomb you know
product that makes things different on a
daily basis it's really important what
you do he said before to say and in a
world of social media
everyone just talk to everyone we have
all these teacher communities some of
them have over 8,000 members one of our
teacher communities on Facebook run by a
teacher called Shannon Marie and she was
invited to the Facebook summit thing in
Chicago with a hundred and ten community
years and she's one of them very proud
and people like her are advocating we
have kid across the board and we just
want launch our summer to office this
year so we have a very experienced
veterans in a tech community like Kevin
Kling who travels across the u.s. and go
to every state and meet with every other
teachers and
this every month I think we have over 50
teacher initiated meetups so it's not
yes then but then we have people as
teacher evangelist to go there and talk
to them all the time yeah that's the
power of the community I mean it's so
fascinating to hear you almost have
three sides you have the child you have
the parent and you have the teachers and
they're quite distributed and you've
gotten you know both sides to sort of
work with each other to build this you
know what what is your vision for VIP
kid like five years from now what do you
think it would be Oh 5 to 10 years I
think we we would would love to have a
children across the globe to be able to
learn with VIP kid and though we're
seeing five to ten million kids learn
and we want to work with many more
teachers and make both students and
teachers life and learning experience
teaching students really very different
and I think what's more important is a
long longer mission our mission is to
inspire and empower every child for the
future so if you think about it 63% of
our high school kids yeah
fifty sixty three of our rural kids in
China does not get to go to high school
and the two billion of the world
population still lives on a three US
dollar per day costs right so the world
of learning is so essential to our
humankind that if met me online learning
today
it really has a possibility to be the
game changer for the future and then
with the you know online learning things
can be way more efficient in ethnic
issues and also the the cost is gonna be
much lower and then if we can just bring
this to every child in the you know in
the in the world this can be really
great and then also the world is gonna
be very different in the next 20 30 40
years and schools are gonna be very
different so what do child need for the
future
can we you know embed all these love of
learning and competence of future for
them in the things that we teach them so
I think our dream is really to be able
to do that across board not just to the
families who can afford it today but
also to
families that can not afford it you know
today but you know in the in the future
maybe if we can build something for them
it'd be really great
just possibility of really imagine me
thinking what a creative education can
look like at a global level in the next
10 20 years it's very very exciting to
the to the team and it's part of the
reason that we're also building a growth
in the AI team here in San Mateo it's
all the learning science that we need to
discover working with the Daphne Koller
from she used to be professor in
Stanford and co-founder Coursera and a
Stanford professor bruce mccandless on
children's our early childhood education
and and also a few others I mean so for
all these professors I think it's very
grateful for us to be working with them
to figure things out so we can build
this amazing future two together that is
a that's such a wonderful mission
I mean kudos to you for you know sort of
starting it from age 15 and sort of
realizing it and being able to you know
almost deliver on that mission
right and you've already started that
with English and I know you have plans
to do the rivers I know a lot of us kids
would be interested in learning Mandarin
and I thought it was interesting you
mentioned AI I mean I think it's almost
becoming a common theme across most
products and especially in China I've
seen a lot more companies put AI at the
forefront of it can you talk a little
more about half you see AI in EdTech and
it's particularly in the epic eight is
it about a personalized curriculum like
what what is sort of your vision there
yeah our vision with AI is to be able to
personalize students learning and also
to empower our teachers in their work so
we have after compression every month
over 100 Tiger byte of data so it's a
lot of data and then we were the we
might be the only company that processes
all these uh audio/video content
interaction of students teachers and all
these are learning data across board so
we then have a good opportunity to
figure out what motivates student to
learn
how does a teacher work the best how do
we match students and teachers how do we
personalize their learning path so there
are a lot of things we can discover from
all these amazing data and I'll you know
be really great to find the best people
in the industry I mean before people
wouldn't think about that tag they would
think about all the other companies but
if you think about the attack today
there are quite a few companies that are
in the unicorn family already so people
thinking oh this might have a future and
also many of their kids are users of
these products so people from the growth
teams of share economy marketplace
companies or top-tier AI people and
researchers also from university they're
they're interested and see this
possibility of how this can be really
different so also talking about teachers
empowerment if you think about teacher
stops really hard how do you remember
every of your student how do you
remember every little details of how
they work and how do you real-time
respond to other interactions in the
classroom the best help them so it's a
lot of hard work I think with AI
everything can be made a lot easier and
the teachers can just do what they're
best at and then if the work is more
efficient they can probably make more
money income in the given amount of time
that they work with a kid so it'd be
very beneficial for both the kids and
the teachers and parents of course they
would always want to see like how their
children are doing and all these would
just bring a whole lot benefit to
everyone well thank you so much Cindy
for taking the time I'm sure you know a
lot of our audience would have gotten a
lot from how you know how much you've
really persevered and congratulations on
all the progress I think you so much I
know for having me thank you
you